sentir
[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a esta nueva misión
de los observadores de france 24 cierre
blanco y como siempre un gusto
acompañarlos en esta oportunidad
iniciamos en islas canarias donde un
migrante nos informó sobre su difícil
situación las difíciles condiciones de
vida que enfrenta en un centro de
cuarentena donde se encuentra albergado
y luego vamos a pasar a la república
democrática del congo a las orillas del
lago tanganika donde se desbordó por
segundo año consecutivo y miles de
personas quedaron sin hogar y sin
asistencia
no así la vamos
en 2020 más de 23.000 migrantes llegaron
a las islas canarias desde áfrica con el
sueño de ir a europa continental sin
embargo la mayoría de ellos siguen
varados allí en condiciones difíciles
especialmente los que están en
cuarentena tras dar positivos por joven
19 o por ser casos de contacto esto es
lo que explica un joven guineano que
alertó a nuestra redacción desde la isla
de fuerteventura llevamos 35 días aquí
durante el día lo único que hacemos es
dormirnos salimos todo está cerrado los
baños están al lado de donde dormimos va
más allá comemos hacemos todo a veces si
los baños están llenos se desborda el
agua es difícil no podemos vivir aquí es
imposible además no tenemos suficiente
comida ni agua para beber lo apoyarme
aquí la gente está enferma física y
psicológicamente y su color
amnistía internacional señaló que el
centro de cuarentena no cumplía con las
condiciones sanitarias mínimas las
autoridades españolas anunciaron que el
centro será cerrado próximamente pero no
dieron una fecha los inmigrantes que no
se encuentran en cuarentena son
agrupados en su mayoría en centros donde
la incertidumbre y la falta de
acompañamiento generan tensiones en la
isla de tenerife se produjeron
enfrentamientos en el macro campamento
de las raíces que alberga a más de mil
inmigrantes nuestro observador miembro
de un colectivo ciudadano opina que este
lugar no brinda una acogida digna al ser
las condiciones muy malas el que sean
chicos cables de diferentes
nacionalidades que hablan diferentes
idiomas la necesidad de comida que está
escasa el pan pasando frío pues ha
generado mucho conflicto
entendemos que si hubiera más psicólogos
más abogados y trabajadores sociales no
se crearían estos problemas muchos
todavía no han podido hablar los
abogados han podido solicitar el papel
de los mmo desde el 15 de febrero
salieron 25 personas por fuera a
protestar por las malas condiciones en
las que estaban dentro del macro
campamento y porque querían que se les
diera una solución han recibido apoyo de
la asamblea de apoyo a migrantes
tenerife que se les ha ayudado con
comida caliente con ropa se les ha
traído caseta está claro que desde
europa y sobre todo desde españa se ha
decidido de convertir canarias en una
cárcel el gobierno español afirma que
muchos de los migrantes que han llegado
han sido trasladados a otras partes de
españa devueltos a sus países de origen
o se han ido por su cuenta sólo 7.000
inmigrantes entre ellos dos mil menores
permanecen en las estructuras estatales
a los que hay que añadir aquellos que
viven en campamentos informales según
las asociaciones
cómo
ese es el campamento improvisado en el
que viven las víctimas de las
inundaciones masivas que afectaron a la
ciudad de uvira en kivú del sur al este
de la república democrática del congo a
mediados de abril varias semanas de
lluvias torrenciales han provocado una
inundación sin precedentes del lago
tanganika en más de 6000 casas fueron
arrasadas según nuestro observador
algunas de estas casas se derrumbaron y
otras siguen en pie pero el agua alcanza
hasta los 3 metros de altura la
situación la situación humanitaria de
las víctimas de la catástrofe es
deplorable porque están encerradas en
los refugios sitios se trata de
instalaciones improvisadas creadas por
ellos mismos
en este momento las víctimas necesitan
toda la ayuda posible qué es eso y
auxiliares que también existe el riesgo
de contraer enfermedades transmitidas
por el agua porque no tienen baños no
tienen agua potable luz
ni siquiera tienen agua para las tareas
domésticas
pero además no tienen mosquiteros así
que los niños y las mujeres embarazadas
sobre todo se contagian de paludismo o
malaria porque estamos en una zona con
muchos mosquitos y a poco de mustique en
2020 la primera inundación del lago
tanganika y sus afluentes causó la
muerte de unas 40 personas y desplazó a
miles debido al cambio climático las
temporadas de lluvias son cada vez más
intensas por lo tanto las inundaciones
son más frecuentes pero los
especialistas también culpan a la
sobreexplotación de las zonas que rodean
el lago en particular la construcción
desordenada de casas que hay una norma
que prohíbe construir a menos de 50
metros de la orilla pero la gente la
ignora ahora el agua llega hasta un
kilómetro adentro
la gente lleva años construyendo cerca
del lago y las autoridades no han hecho
nada
y siquiera se molestaron en decirle a la
gente que no debía construir en
determinadas zonas
si eso se aprende es un quiso
realmente milagro es tanganika y si
nosotros donde prácticas tenga
le pedimos al estado congoleño que
socorra y ayude a estas personas que
fueron abandonadas a su triste suerte
porque desde enero hasta hoy no han
recibido ayuda en estado congoleños ni
siquiera ayudó a los afectados del año
pasado al ser contactada a la alcaldía
de hubiera reconoció la mala gestión de
la distribución de las parcelas pero
culpa a sus predecesores sin embargo la
alcaldía dice que no tiene medios para
atender las necesidades de las víctimas
y esta manera llegamos al final de los
observadores por esta semana no olvide
que todos nuestros contactos aparecen en
pantalla donde esperamos sus fotos y
videos aficionados hasta una próxima
oportunidad
[Música]